obviously he has the skill set
uh you know the talent of the arm
throwing the ball on the move you know
to escape pressure all those things um
you know i think the future's bright
there'll be a probably a change in the
footwork um i have a belief and a
philosophy of footwork and it's
extremely important to me
kevin is light as as well
you know it all starts with the feet the
feet never lie
they get you through your progressions
uh so just some of the ways that we'll
have him drop both from under center and
the gun will change slightly to help
alex van pelt new offensive coordinator
of the cleveland browns with some ideas
on how to get more out of baker mayfield
who was very very good chris as a rookie
but then last year it just went the
other way what's your reaction when you
hear the assessment from alex van pelt
as to what they want to do with baker
mayfield and how easy or difficult will
it be to implement those kinds of
changes in one off season right well i
like what alex van pelt said i do and i
think he's spot on with probably that
being the biggest issue with baker
mayfield you know just the things i saw
during the year now yeah your question
about how easy is this to fix it's
pretty easy it really is this is a thing
that can be ingrained into a quarterback
pretty quickly through otas or even just
drill work before otas even start but
mike you know we did a we did a few
tapes during the year about aaron baker
mayfield throws right we talked about it
a lot we talked about a few row areas of
the field where he always seemed to be
off target and through interceptions a
lot and a lot of those problems more
than anything were his feet you know i
always say if you put yourself in the
middle of the clock when baker mayfield
wanted to throw to 12 o'clock man he
stepped at 10 and 9 o'clock a whole lot
and you know i i don't this is a great
example there you go a ball four feet
behind him if you're watching on tv to
duke johnson he's trying to throw the
ball to 11 o'clock and he's stepping at
eight o'clock and of course yes the ball
is not going to be consistently accurate
that way so this is something that i saw
that i thought certainly slipped from
year one to year two with baker mayfield
here's a stupid question yeah and it may
not be that's no such thing i'm
acknowledging the possibility no there's
just stupid people who ask questions
that's an old chris berman line how much
of baker mayfield last year was him
trying to be patrick mahomes oh i i do
think he had pro he pressed at points i
do i think with trying just the whole
idea that the whole idea that that he
can throw from any body position he
should throw from any arm angle footwork
doesn't matter to him right if he can do
it i can do it i don't need to be
obsessed about this how you stand how
you step how you turn your body if he
can whip it around so can i uh that's my
that's my question i think sometimes i
think there's something last year no i
think there's something there mike you
know i i noticed another topic we talked
about early in the year where i felt
like he was trying to throw the ball too
hard and too aggressively like reaching
back really far to get extra mile per
hours on the ball which was leading to a
lot of inconsistencies with his release
and i do think it was a little bit
because of the
you know sex appeal of oh i'm going to
throw a laser and i'm going to throw a
sidearm laser and all those things and
yeah but when you do that uh it it
creates more room for errors so i do
think there was something to that and
alex van pelt made another good point
where he just said the feet never lie
you know hey you know the feet are a
great thing for a young quarterback to
keep you on track with discipline right
mike that's where it really is it's like
okay you know to throw the curl there's
a curl route on the left and then
there's going to be a guy in the flat
you know they'll teach it to where take
five steps and on your first hitch if
the curls open throw it but now when
you're starting to get to the second
hitch and the curl is not there we'd
like you to start going to the flat
route so it's almost like a little
checks and balance for your brain to be
like okay wait i'm holding the ball too
long here i've taken three hitches and
i'm still waiting for the curl and
that's when you throw an interception or
gets sacked fumbled or anything like
that so i do think this is something
that will help him unless you're patrick
mahomes see that's what i keep coming
back well it doesn't matter competitors
in the big 12 and baker mayfield beat
him and he's got to have that in his
head he's seeing this guy who he may be
regarded as lesser than him in college
yeah explode and he can't keep up with
it no no and he's trying to keep up with
the way my home does he just has to
accept
no one is going to be no one is all
right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports